c'est décidé les mairies ne veulent plus
voir deux voitures sur leurs trottoirs
du coup les places des centres-villes
disparaissent à paris pas moins de 10000
places ont été ainsi supprimés et pour
se garer sans payer il faut se lever de
bonne heure en cinq ans les
stationnements gratuits sont passées de
36 mille à deux mille sept cents
aujourd'hui les places sont rares et de
plus en plus cher cet été le prix des
parcmètres de la capitale augmenté d'un
coût de 20 pour cent se garer en ville
est devenue un véritable enfer
c'est un terrible à paris puis ça
devient de plus en plus cher en plus
pris peu de jeu ils font rien pour les
voitures c'est quoi compliquer un toute
façon je paye même plus une station
ça finit par coûter trop cher le
stationnement à paris dans le faire
court épouvantable c'est un des moyens
employés pour éradiquer la voiture ou
paris la galère pour les automobilistes
un business très juteux pour d'autres à
qui profite la politique du zéro voiture
en ville
comment est répartie l'argent des
parkings publics et avec une place de
stationnement peut-on gagner plus
d'argent qu'avec la bourse
combien ça coûte l'hebdo a mené l
enquête bienvenue au touquet ses plages
ses cerfs-volants et désormais ses
places de parking à un pitoyable
ici ils ont trouvé le moyen imparable
pour verbaliser tous les fraudeurs dans
le centre-ville on peut se garer
gratuitement mais attention pas plus
d'une heure quand les 3600 secondes sont
dépassés christine emmanuel et julien
interviennent les places du centre ville
les plus recherchés sont dotés de bornes
dernière génération une machine dernier
cri des capteurs au sol
high tech ça revient 1000 euros la place
le système est redoutable versé bon
rouge
il y a du souci à se faire
c'est pour un dépannage gardez vous avez
la place du marché qui est gratuite
madame balance marbocyl madame c'est des
stations bord d'une heure donc au bout
d'une heure ça se déclencher la machine
ne peut pas se tromper
alors on ne la fait pas à christine
aussitôt qu'ils franchissent la ligne
la bande se déclenche et elles partent
elle part avec un décompte de 60 minutes
dont clé dans le vert forcément est
aussitôt qu'elle passe dans le rouge que
les 60 minutes sont écoulées nous à ce
moment là ses appels police non
seulement ces horodateurs calcul pour
eux le temps passé sur une place mais en
plus ils jouent les mouchards et une
infraction au prix de paris 8 paris 52
rue de paris les automobilistes ne
peuvent même plus compter sur la pause
café des forces de l'ordre ou le mauvais
temps pour déjouer leur vigilance à la
rumeur on verbalise
la police municipale est prévenue des
infractions en temps réel grâce au
téléphone portable
les gens sont arrivés vous quand vous
mettez ça passe dans le vert et ses 11
euros d'amendé ça passe dans le rouge
c'est pas mal quand on comprend le
système désolé j'ai pas compris
donc je voulais ses chevaux que je
dresse il va donc falloir y regarder à
deux fois avant de se garer
certains petits malins ont quand même
trouvé le moyen de berne et l'ordinateur
il suffit de quitter sa place quelques
secondes et c'est reparti pour une heure
de stationnement gratuit c'est interdit
si on se fait pincer ses 11 euros
damende encore
le touquet l'a adopté d'autres villes
commencent à s'y mettre issy les
moulineaux bastia poitiers ces bornes
anti fraude poule décidément comme des
champignons à strasbourg si on a préféré
garder ses bons vieux horodateurs c'est
que la mairie a déclaré la guerre aux
voitures dans le centre-ville le parking
aux abords de la cathédrale va être
supprimé 5000 nouvelles places gratuites
vont devenir payantes et le tarif qui
sera plus cher qu'ailleurs
résultat il est 7 heures du matin et il
n'ya déjà presque plus un emplacement de
libre dans le plus grand parking public
de strasbourg
normal il est devenu impossible de se
garer en ville
11h15 des lignes ennemies ça fait 3
euros car en voyant les catcheurs
mais bon y'a pas le choix les parkings
publics non deux publics que le nom en
fait ce sont des concessionnaires privés
qui les gère françois le vert travail
pour le numéro un du business ces cinq
parkings strasbourgeois rapporte trois
millions sept cent mille euros par an à
sa société
en contrepartie il verse un peu plus de
cinq cent mille euros chaque année aux
propriétaires qui n'est autre que la
mairie on dit que les villes sont très
saturées de voitures qu'il ya trop de
voitures dedans et bien s'il y a moins
de voitures ce sera certainement parfait
à condition qu'elle soit là où elles
doivent être et si elles sont chez nous
elle dit seront très bien et pour mieux
faire passer la facture les sociétés de
parking rivalisent d'ingéniosité
peinture lumineuse ascenseurs
panoramiques petite musique d'ambiance
prêt de vélos des parapluies et des
cabas mis gracieusement à disposition
des promotions à gogo et cerise sur le
gâteau 24 heures de parking gratuit le
jour de son anniversaire
c'est tout simplement faire détonner
avec l'ancienne image du parking convoi
dans l'est dans les polars parking look
sombre dans lesquels les femmes ne
s'aventurent pas
ici on axe sur une luminosité importante
pour que les
les femmes et autres se sentent à l'aise
mais il ya encore plus fort vous
connaissiez déjà les centres de lavage
ou les stations essence dans les
parkings publics à strasbourg c'est un
salon de coiffure qui vient d'ouvrir
entre la rampe d'accès les caisses de
paiement la propriétaire a déboursé près
d'un million d'euros pour transformer ce
bout de bitume en temple de la beauté
bien des fois on vivre simplement pour
aller chez le coiffeur et on trouve pas
de place pour se garer donc là elles
viennent elles ont directement un
emplacement de parking
elle se coiffe et puis ensuite elles
peuvent partir et le salon ne désemplit
pas depuis son ouverture en mai dernier
se faire coiffer au milieu des gaz
d'échappement ça n'a pas l'air
d'effrayer les clientes et c'est même
devenu une véritable attraction ça
attire vraiment c'est vraiment et puis
s'il ya vraiment un contraste entre le
parking et le salon une fois qu'on est
dans le salon le parking
on ne voit pratiquement plus vous n'avez
pas l'impression d'être en vitrine
ah non non non dit et à la sortie même
s'il pleut aucun risque de ruiner sa
permanente la voiture attend l étage à
l'abri
le bonheur gagner de l'argent grâce au
parking vous allez voir que c'est aussi
possible pour peu qu'on ait le sens des
affaires
jean-marc journaux est un agent
immobilier un peu spécial dans sa
vitrine pas de photos de maisons ou
d'appartements juste des plans de paris
il vend exclusivement des places de
parking il est le seul à faire ça en
france donc un parti combien ça coûte
alors le le gros du marché se trouve
entre 20000 et 35000 euros sur paris
après on a des extrêmes bon ça peut
démarrer à 9000 et 10000 euros la place
et de l'autre côté aussi on peut
atteindre
on est des extrêmes à 150000 euros c'est
un placement qui rapporte 5 5% à la
location par an aujourd'hui jean marc a
rendez vous avec un client qui veut
acheter six places ce jeune homme ne
possède pas si voiture mais il à 150000
euros investir ça se passe comme pour la
visite d'un appartement
donc là c'est l'axé par les parties
communes donc voilà le parcours en un
peu plus rapide
bon je vous voyais s'était refait les
peintures on était complètement refaite
l'éclairage a été refait ce qui compte
surtout c'est le nombre de mètres carrés
4 m 82 c'est suffisamment grand pour un
4 4 pour descendre est suffisamment
large pour un conducteur maladroit
à ce prix là le moindre recoin mise à
profit dans ses parts égales à 60 euros
en fait c'est une place moto celle c'est
une place smart on va dire il y a cinq
ans ce jeune commercial avait déjà
acheté cinq places et ce qu'il aime dans
ce placement
c'est qu'il n'a rien à faire l'avantagé
que part qu'il n'y a pas de choisir qui
tombe en panne ya pas de locataire qui
ne paie pas ses loyers
et si beaucoup plus sûre à ce niveau là
et à la revente en plus on est toujours
gagnant ce n'est pas la mairie de paris
qui dira le contraire elle a vendu un
parking dans le quartier le plus
recherché de la capitale pour le prix
d'un très beau trois pièces 470 mille
euros aux enchères
le propriétaire n'a pas souhaité se
faire connaître mais à ce prix là il
paraît qu'il a la voiture qui va avec